bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans Sciences publiques pour
90 minutes de débats de reportage et
d'analyse sur Public Sénat avec nos
experts on cherche à donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des crises que nous
traversons et justement il y a encore
beaucoup de questions de mystère autour
de des ballons et autres objets volants
non-identifier ah bah tu ces derniers
jours au-dessus du territoire
nord-américains qui espionne qui quelles
conséquence sur les relations entre la
Chine et les États-Unis espionnage
militaire et économique sont-ils liés en
temps de l'ivoire plus clair dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
on va parler du partage des richesses un
thème d'actualité puisque les
partenaires sociaux ont annoncé vendredi
un accord sur l'intéressement et la
participation des salariés dans les
entreprises pourtant le patronat était
pessimiste
il y a quelques semaines j'avais
qualifié cette négociation d'impossible
et pourtant nous l'avons fait nous avons
dépassé nos divergences nous avons fait
mentir ce qui pense que la négociation
la démocratie sociale sont des concepts
dépassés comment mieux partager la
valeur dans les entreprises faut-il
aller plus loin en lançant comme le
Crédit Mutuel ou la MAIF un dividende
écologique et sociétales pour financer
les startups ou des associations réponse
dans trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord
l'histoire d'un bras de fer en haute
altitude racontée par Jonathan Dupriez
Caroline du Sud le 4 février dernier un
avion de chasse de l'US Air Force abat
d'un missile un étrange ballon survolant
depuis plusieurs jours le territoire
américain à 12000 mètres d'altitude
ils ont tabattu le ballon avec succès et
je veux féliciter les pilotes qu'ils
l'ont fait et nous aurons plus à en dire
d'ici peu pour Washington pas de doute
il s'agit d'un ballon chinois espionnant
des sites militaires des accusations
fermement démenties par Pékin pour qui
cet aéronef civil n'est utilisé qu'à des
fins de recherche météorologiques pour
les Chinois cet usage de la force est
donc disproportionné il s'agissait d'un
incident inattendu de force majeure qui
ne pouvait être contrôlée mais les
États-Unis l'ont quand même délibérément
amplifiées et l'ont même attaqué par la
force c'est un comportement inacceptable
et irresponsable depuis les tensions mon
cessé de croître entre les deux
superpuissants s'accusant réciproquement
d'espionnage la crise est même montée
encore d'un cran ce weekend lorsque les
Américains ont battu trois nouveaux
ballons de plus petites tailles s'ils
n'ont pas été identifiés à ce stade la
Maison Blanche n'exclut pas la thèse
d'un possible espionnage d'ampleur de
son territoire
même si nous n'avons eu aucune
indication que ces trois objets
faisaient de la surveillance nous
n'avons pas pu l'exclure il faut donc
privilégier la prudence pour protéger
nos intérêts en matière de sécurité
nationale
alimentant un contrefeu Pékin à son tour
affirmé que les États-Unis avaient
survolé à plus de 10 reprises l'Empire
du Milieu depuis 2022 avec des ballons
similaires cette grave crise
diplomatique survient sur fond de
concurrence entre Washington et Pékin
depuis des années les deux puissances
luttent pour obtenir le leadership
économique technologique et stratégique
du monde je vous présente tout de suite
mes invités Jérôme claesh bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes enseignants
prospective et stratégie à Sciences Po
Paris Valéry Niquet bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi spécialiste de
l'Asie à la Fondation pour la recherche
stratégique et vous publiez ce livre la
Chine en 100 questions aux éditions
Talandier Jean-François bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sur un professeur
d'économie et président de
l'INALCO et miliza palski bonsoir
bienvenue Emilie spécialiste en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens publique alors je vais
commencer là on a parlé du
essentiellement du premier ballon
chinois donc je rappelle un peu le
calendrier 4 février chasseur F22
américain qui a base ballon ensuite il y
a eu
février l'armée qui a un objet volant à
hôteltitude au dessus de l'Alaska
l'armée américaine 11 février deux
avions américains deux avions Canadiens
cette fois-ci parlent abaque et par un
objet non identifié violent l'espace
aérien canadien et puis le 12 février de
chasseurs FCF qui détruisent un objet de
forme cylindrique au-dessus du lacon
dans le Michigan Jérôme claesh est-ce
que c'est vraiment nouveau où est-ce que
c'est la première fois que ça passe au
dessus des radars vous voyez que pour
les médias généralistes et c'est au sens
propre et au sens figuré comme vous
dites la première fois les solutions par
hasard voilà au-dessus des radars donc
en ce sens c'est nouveau et c'est
nouveau parce que ça convoque des enjeux
s'agissant de ce qu'on appelle la Hao
c'est-à-dire la ailleurs espère son père
et chaîne c'est une zone d'opération
dans la haute altitude qui est pour
faire simple une zone grise en fait
parce que c'est à la fois une zone de
souveraineté pour les états et en même
temps ce n'est pas une zone de contrôle
avec des prérogatives des compétences
juridiques
[Musique]
qui rentre dans la zone d'identification
aérienne de défense taïwanaise c'est une
incursion et c'est une violation
d'espace de souveraineté pour autant
c'est pas un espace contrôlé au sens
juridique du terme par Taiwan et on est
exactement en cette configuration là
sauf que ce qui se pose sur le plan
vertical ici avec nos avions avec nos
ballons s'oppose sur le plan sur le plan
c'est le cas de le dire horizontal pour
Taïwan lorsque deuxième exemple la
Russie relie le territoire russe à
l'enclave où l'esclave je ne sais pas
comment il faut l'appeler de Kaliningrad
bon bah ces chasseurs ou c'est
bombardiers et corne très fréquemment
l'espace aérien contrôlé estonien on y
reviendra là dessus je vais évidemment
vous redonner la parole la dernière
information cette fin d'après-midi
communiquer de la Maison Blanche alors
pas sur le premier ballon dont on
parlait dans le sujet de Jonathan du
prisme mais sur les autres objets alors
on dit OVNI
identifié ça ça ouvre évidemment des
perspectives autre mais bon voilà
très intéressant cette communication
Valérie voilà les termes employés
par la Maison Blanche les États-Unis ont
reconnu que les objets volants qu'ils
ont abattus en fin de semaine dernière
avec au passage un tir de missiles raté
était peut-être inoffensif voilà ces
objets pourraient être des ballons avec
des fonctions commerciales ou
scientifiques inoffensives comment vous
analysez ce communique on a quand même
l'impression du côté des États-Unis qui
n'ont pas envie d'en faire une tonne sur
ces nouveaux objets tout au tout de même
en les ayant abattu donc il y a une
sorte de en même temps un peu
particulier mais évidemment le poids le
plus important pour les États-Unis
c'était ce premier très gros ballon qui
a très vite été identifié comme chinois
qui n'avait rien à faire là et qui avait
qui est d'ailleurs avait une trajectoire
qui survolait des zones sensibles
puisque il y a des bases de lancement
des missiles intercontinentaux
américains qui se trouvait là donc ça
c'était un vrai sujet et surtout le
ballon a été vu par tout le monde donc
même le point de départ pardon nous
interrompre c'est un civil qui
effectivement je pense que c'est
effectivement pas la première fois c'est
quelque chose qui arrive régulièrement
et les opérations d'espionnage que ce
soit de la part des États-Unis et des
Chinois évidemment qui ont un vrai
objectif c'est très courant simplement
normalement on ne le voit pas et donc on
peut éventuellement gérer ça entre
honorable correspondant si on te dit et
puis faire en sorte de d'étouffer
l'affaire il y a déjà eu des ballons qui
ont sur le chinois qui ont survolé le
territoire américain donc là on a un peu
la pression que les États-Unis ne sont
pas sûr d'abord de ce que sont c'est
beaucoup plus petits objets et
deuxièmement l'ont pas envie
immédiatement d'attaquer frontalement
Pékin tout en ayant abattu les ballons
et on voyait pendant que vous nous
parliez cette vidéo effectivement
Jean-François est-ce que ce premier
ballon il a parce que il a mis la Chine
dans l'embarras on y reviendra mais
peut-être il a mis aussi les États-Unis
dans l'embarras certaines façons oui je
pense que c'est bien réagir quoi je
pense que c'est avant tout des questions
de politique intérieure dans dans chacun
des pays
on est d'ailleurs on a vu tout de suite
après les républicains ont réagi en
disant mais comment ça vous démocrate
vous n'êtes pas capable d'assurer la
sécurité de nos frontières et tout de
suite l'armée a publié quelque chose en
disant mais sous Trump il y en a eu
quatre qui serait passé donc du coup on
a on a mis la balle au centre on va dire
comme ça et côté chinois je pense qu'il
y avait un embarras certains
moi j'ai du mal à croire à une thèse de
déstabilisation
d'une partie qui serait on va dire plus
à droite ou plus à gauche que c'est une
pink qui aurait voulu déstabiliser un
peu la visite et entorse
américain sont très embarrassés par ça
et que ils avaient envie d'avoir une des
escalade suite aux suite à leur
rencontre
lors des sommets asiatiques qui sont
déroulés à la fin de l'année 2022 et
notamment on pourrait essayer d'avoir
effectivement des dispositifs qui
permettent d'éviter une escalade
notamment vers Taïwan ou là les avions
volent et risques peut-être des
accidents comme on en a eu parfois par
le passé mais sans avoir la tension
sous-jacente qu'on a maintenant et je
pense que les deux pays sont assez
embarrassés aujourd'hui par cette
histoire des ballons je reviens quand
même sur ce communiqué de la Maison
Blanche ces objets pourraient être je me
répète un déballons avec des fonctions
commerciales ou scientifiques
inoffensives Jérôme kleix ça doit pas
être si compliqué de savoir d'où ils
viennent c'est c'est ces objets alors il
est clair que les États-Unis là prennent
beaucoup de précautions et ce
font des efforts pour rester extrêmement
factuels et éviter de verser dans
l'hypothèse néanmoins si nous en tant
qu'analiste je parle pour moi j'allais
du côté de l'hypothèse en fonction de ce
que je sais quand je vois le ballon très
clairement ça ne ressemble pas à un
ballon
dédié à de la météorologie le premier
ballon le premier ballon le premier là
il parle des autres objets là les autres
les autres je ne les ai pas vu et ils
parlent aux conditionnel de ballon parce
que pour l'instant ce qui est dit à
l'indicatif par le Pentagone sur les
autres objets c'est uniquement la forme
cylindrique et octogonale pour le
troisième sans aller sur la possibilité
que ce soit un ballon voilà mais quand
tu dis scientifique ou commercial il y a
quand même là aussi vous lui dites c'est
un peu une zone grise mais n'importe
quelle entreprise a décidé d'envoyer un
objet dans cette zone là c'est là où
j'en viens c'est que si on regarde
encore une fois pas le deuxième et le
troisième objet parce que là je ne les
ai pas vu mais s'agissant du premier
ballon un ballon météorologique ça ne
ressemble pas à ça d'accord souviens
avoir fait ma thèse sur une vingtaine de
ballons stratosphériques fait par le
CNES et évocation à étudier le
tourbillon Antarctique qui en gros c'est
l'endroit où se situe le trou dans la
couche d'ozone voilà bon bah ça ne
ressemble pas du tout à ça en fait et
puis ça s'inscrit dans une grande
campagne avec des demandes
d'autorisation avec
tout ce qu'il faut pour mener une
campagne scientifique si vous voulez de
façon un peu systémique c'est pas un
ballon comme ça qui se perdent dans
l'atmosphère et duquel on attendrait
qu'il nous donne des données
météorologiques donc je comprends en
fait toutes les inquiétudes que ont pu
avoir les États-Unis s'agissant de la
volonté de surveillance qui pourrait y
avoir à travers ce ballon là qui
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant et passer
au-dessus de deux zones de points
sensibles voilà Emilie on a l'impression
que la communication de Joe Biden a été
un petit peu forcée parce que vous
disiez c'est que des civils ont vu ces
objets là et du coup toute cette
diplomatie qui se fait probablement en
dessous quoi entre entre responsables
elle a été obligatoirement mise à jour
parce que on ne pouvait pas et vous
l'avez dit il y a des oppositions aussi
politiques on ne pouvait pas Joe Biden
ne pouvait pas ne rien dire mais c'est
vrai que c'est étonnant parce que d'un
coup on se dit alors ça veut dire que
l'espace américain peut être survolé
comme ça à cette hauteur là est-ce que
les Américains utilisent les mêmes
stratégies est-ce que c'est de nouveau
moyen d'espionnage un peu locaux
puisqu'on voit passer des choses qui
existaient même auparavant c'est quelque
chose de pas très cher finalement mais
qui peut être assez rentable en matière
d'espionnage alors ça peut être à la
fois locaux et puis
icoste parce que si vous envisagez des
objets supersoniques ou hypersoniques
comme des missiles qui investissent
cette achat eau cette zone dont on
parlait là ça devient très cher ce sont
typiquement des missiles comme ceux que
la Russie met en avant dans ses armes
dites du manège des missiles avant-garde
ou même Vénissieux d'observation ou non
là mais c'est toute la militarisation
qui a derrière et c'est les enjeux qui a
en fait derrière cette nouvelle zone
grise en fait c'est pour ça que là et
sur la partie plutôt ICOS alors
puisqu'on parlait de communication du
gouvernement américain un premier
exemple prise de parole de net Price qui
est porte-parole du Département d'État
américain l'équivalent du ministère des
Affaires étrangères sur la les
technologies ce que la récupération du
ballon chinois a permis regardez
nous avons pris des mesures concrètes
depuis la détection de ce ballon de
surveillance à haute altitude pour
limiter sa capacité à recueillir des
renseignements sur des sites sensibles
pour limiter toute menace pour le peuple
américain
d'une certaine manière nous avons
renversé la situation parce que nous
avons développé de nombreuses capacités
propres à ce ballon de surveillance à
haute altitude alors qu'il violait notre
espace aérien nous avons appris beaucoup
de choses à son sujet et sur la pratique
en général sur la technologie qui était
à bord
on parle d'espionnage militaire
d'espionnage économique les deux sont
liés ce ballon il peut servir aux deux
qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer on peut
faire techniquement je peux pas vous
répondre
parce que je suis pas un expert de je
pense que
l'espionnage y compris il y a des fins
économiques se fait par des voix
régaliennes et militaires en particulier
donc le ballon il peut servir aux deux
complètement et je complète le propos à
la fois sur l'aspect plutôt low cost ma
relativisé quand même parce que c'est
pas si low cost que ça et sur ce à quoi
ressemble ce ballon là si vous regardez
les projets qui se développent au niveau
européen je pense au projet dit de la
coopération structurée permanente pour
faire simple c'est des pays européens
qui se mettent ensemble avec des
industriels en cluster pour développer
des nouvelles capacités qui seraient
utiles et des capacités qui se
réutilisent pour investiguer ce chant
des 20 100 km cette zone grise justement
et bien il y a un projet qui s'appelle
typiquement stratobus voilà c'est un
projet européen et si vous regardez
stratobus une plateforme de haute
altitude avec un ballon un dirigeable un
peu plus forme un peu plus oblongue que
celui-ci mais on est typiquement dans
cette morphologie là ce qui est très
différent du ballon du ballon
météorologique même si vous pouvez
effectivement collecter tout un tas de
données à des fins purement purement
civils et en général vous mettez plutôt
des capteurs pour de l'interception de
communication la surveillance hossegol
des capteurs optiques électromagnétiques
et pour faire ce que les satellites font
mais avec une autre approche qui est
celle de pouvoir rester au dessus d'une
zone de couvrir une zone dans la durée
ce que peut faire un satellite
géostationnaire mais c'est beaucoup très
c'est beaucoup plus cher là ça le fait
pour un prix plus abordable
je voulais qu'on évoque le le peut-être
nickel le contexte de de guerlarer entre
les États-Unis et la Chine c'est
peut-être aussi en sac cet épisode est
intéressant oui alors effectivement les
tensions sont fortes entre les
États-Unis et la Chine même si comme
François chef de le dire il y avait une
période de manifestement recherche de
d'apaisement de la part des Chinois qui
sont dans une situation assez complexe à
la fois économiquement l'économie
chinoise ne va pas bien ils sont soumis
à des sanctions américaines aussi bien
en terme de transfert de technologie que
d'accès au marché américain or
actuellement les exportations c'est ce
qui tirent la croissance chinoise
essentiellement donc enfin ça va
peut-être changer avec la levée de la
politique zéro cosyné en face c'est
quelque chose qui est très tendu et on
voit bien que pour Pékin l'idée de
d'essayer de se rapprocher de des
États-Unis avec l'entretien entre
sitting et Joe Biden et d'autres à Bali
à la fin de l'année dernière c'était un
élément extrêmement
important juste pour ces ballons chinois
il faut savoir tout le même qu'ils sont
sous l'autorité sous le contrôle en fait
de l'APL et de y compris en termes de
lancement l'Armée populaire de
libération et donc de la commission
militaire centrale et donc il y a
toujours ça c'est un élément au cœur de
la stratégie de transformation militaire
de la Chine un lien revendiqué très
étroit écrit pas du tout secret entre
industrie civile et militaire donc il y
a pas de distinction le civil sert le
militaire donc un ballon ou un satellite
civil ont évidemment des intérêts en
termes d'observation militaire dans ce
bras de fer économique il y a quoi il y
a une sorte de on accepte de s'espionner
les uns les autres tout le monde sait
qu'on s'espionne les uns les autres ça
fait partie du au même si on essaye de
se protéger de l'empêcher mais bon voilà
ça fait partie du du du de les
connaissances communes quoi ça fait très
longtemps mais bien sûr je sais bien
alors après avant
la mort de Mao il y avait un espionnage
entre guillemets politiques enfin qui
était moins tourné vers l'économique
mais depuis 1978 la Chine n'était pas
dans la même position que celle du Japon
de la Corée c'est à dire la Corée du Sud
qui était qui ont bénéficié des
technologies américaines qui étaient
sous le parapluie nucléaire américain et
qui donc était un peu
une barrières contre le communisme et
qui ont bénéficié justement toute une
série de transferts de technologie la
Chine n'est pas dans cette position et
donc même si
la doctrine de tenkia oping Visé à
apaiser justement les tensions avec les
États-Unis pour pouvoir accéder quand
même à certaines technologies jusqu'à
une période très récente quand même les
technologies que la Chine essayait
d'acquérir était des technologies qui
n'étaient pas encore à la frontière
technologique ce qui ce qui a changé
aujourd'hui c'est que vous avez une
Chine qui est capable de ce qu'on dit
d'ouvrir la boîte noire technologique et
de dire mais ça ça m'intéresse ça ça
m'intéresse parce que le reste je sais
déjà faire et donc ils sont en capacité
de vous voyez de rattraper la frontière
technologique et c'est pour ça que aussi
les Américains les Européens deviennent
extrêmement inquiets de leur avance
technologique et que donc tous les mots
tous les coups sont permis et qu'on
retrouve effectivement de
voilà de l'espionnage économique
industrielle financier
des militaires
un peu partout et entre les deux pays et
imbriqués on l'a bien compris mais quand
vous parlez de cette frontière
technologique c'est relativement je sais
pas si on peut le dater mais c'est
relativement récent ça fait 3 2 3 5 ans
10 ans que on considère que la Chine a
atteint ce niveau-là un secteur ou
effectivement la Chine est arrivé si
vous prenez certains secteurs sur les
batteries par exemple c'est le cas sur
le soleil aussi par contre sur d'autres
sur d'autres secteurs comme les
semi-conducteurs dont on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui la Chine a encore du retard
mais tout le monde se dit regardez où
était la Chine il y a 20 ans et donc il
y a une sorte d'accélération et on se
dit où est-ce qu'on sera dans 10 ans et
quand la Chine effectivement
publie des grands documents en matière
de politique technologique et
industrielle comme ce qu'on a eu il y a
quelques années la Chine 2025 ben il
faisait frais le reste du monde parce
que on sait qu'elles sont leurs moyens
non seulement financiers mais aussi un
point de vue d'espionnage regardez
partout en France aujourd'hui dans les
universités on reçoit aujourd'hui des
indications de la DGSI de la DGSE pour
nous dire faites attention parce que il
peut y avoir de l'espionnage même sur
des choses assez anodines même dans le
domaine des sciences humaines et
sociales je reviens à cette intervention
de net price donc du porte-parole du
Département des Américains quand ils
nous dit Jérôme clay que finalement nous
avons appris beaucoup de choses au sujet
de ce ballon et sur la pratique en
général la technologie qui était à bord
est-ce que effectivement est-ce que vous
croyez effectivement que les Américains
en ont à apprendre et ont pu découvrir
des choses sur les technologies qui
étaient sur ce ballon chinois sans doute
sur les technologies que possèdent les
Chinois de façon maîtrisée ça c'est
surtout c'est sans doute là c'est comme
ça que je comprends la phrase c'est à
dire sur ce que vraiment et maîtriser
par les Chinois et non pas sur la
technologie elle-même ou l'avance
américaine reste quand même reste quand
même évidente alors on va avancer dans
ce débat vous l'avez commencé à
l'évoquer je propose à Quentin calmer de
nous rejoindre sur sur ce plateau pour
parc parler de la réglementation là de
ces zones de d'autres attitudes
bienvenue Quentin alors quelles sont les
règles autour de ces vols en ballon mais
bien c'est ballon en fait ils évoluent
un très haute altitude au dessus de 12
km voyez d'altitude l'atmosphère
terrestre et comme ça découper en
tranches et la première tranche la
troposphère c'est là où volent les
avions de ligne etc et bien les ballons
sont juste au dessus dans la deuxième
couche cela signifie que on pourrait
penser qu'il y a donc des règles
spécifiques en matière voilà de
régulation aérienne mais ce n'est pas le
cas c'est ce que j'ai lu en tout cas
dans cet article de the conversation et
c'est signé par universitaire canadien
selon ce chercheur l'idée simple et
voyelle titre la Chine a enfin les lois
énormes internationales avec son ballon
de surveillance tout simplement parce
que ces ballons ou un mind free blues en
anglais ils sont considérés globalement
comme des avions ou aéronef dans les
réglement internationaux y compris par
la shinto alors quel est la législation
en la matière et bien comme les
diffusion de ligne les ballons doivent
avoir l'accord des pays qu'il survolent
c'est même détaillé par l'agence
onusienne d'organisation de l'aviation
civile internationale rules of the air
le règlement dans le ciel ce texte
comporte une annexe même dédiée au
ballon un ballon libre non habité autre
qu'un ballon léger utilisé exclusivement
à des fins météorologiques ne doivent
pas être exploité sur le territoire d'un
autre État sans l'autorisation
appropriée de l'autre État concerner
c'est ce que dit le texte on voit donc
te maquiller à une dérogation pour
certains ballons météorologiques ce qui
peut expliquer que la Chine insiste sur
le caractère civil de son ballon mais
même dans le cas de cette exception à un
mentionné pour les ballons
météorologiques et bien cette exception
elle est limitée ce même règlement
dispose que les autorités doivent
demander des autorisations au pays
traversés lorsqu'ils préparent l'envoi
de ses ballons et qu'il y a de fort
risque de les voir dérivés à cause du
vent enfin Thomas je voulais finir avec
une dernière info lorsque ces ballons
entre de façon illégale dans le ciel
d'un pays étranger ce ballon doit cesser
son activité selon ce règlement ce qui
n'était pas le cas visiblement avec ces
derniers ballons abattus dans le ciel
des États-Unis merci Quentin je reviens
vers vous Jérôme Jacques parce que moi
quand j'ai vu d'abord le premier ballon
à battu et puis ensuite cette série de
voilà de réaction de de
l'armée de l'air américaine et
canadienne je me suis posé la question
des satellites alors c'est vraiment une
question de bossien parce qu'on est dans
des dans des zones qui sont pas les
mêmes mais si on commence est-ce que ça
crée un précédent d'une certaine façon
ce qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire le fait
d'abattre ces objets dans cette zone
est-ce que ça crée un précédent vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ou est-ce que
finalement on est dans le respect des
règles dans ton dont on parlait à
l'instant à votre question effectivement
ça crée un précédent en ce sens que
j'allais dire toutes les armées de l'air
de façon générique des pays modernes des
démocraties
aurait cette question à traiter
que dois-je faire si j'ai un objet dans
la zone des 20 100 km c'est vraiment
cette zone là qui est importante cette
zone grise là je suis dans un espace de
souveraineté mais ce n'est pas un espace
aérien contrôlé au sens de l'OACI la
Convention de Chicago qu'est-ce que je
fais et là l'autorité qui est en charge
de la décision en fait qui traite au cas
par cas aura effectivement un cas jamais
vu à traiter et en cela ça constitue un
précédent parce que de fait l'autorité
va se reporter à l'existant et va se
dire qu'on fait les États-Unis en Paris
circonstances et en général quand ça
c'est plutôt le prospectiviste qui vous
parle quand on a peu exploré les
scénarios possibles et bien là vous
reportez immédiatement au cas précédent
et vous dites les États-Unis ils ont
attendu sagement que le ballon arrive à
18 km c'est à dire en zone d'un espace
aérien contrôlé dans les eaux
territoriales c'était dans les 12
nautiques des côtes pour l'abattre et en
s'assurant qu'évidemment ça posait pas
de problème en termes de retombées
physiques voilà mais ils ont attendu
d'être dans une situation où il y avait
pas d'ambiguïté juridique parce qu'il
pouvait le faire peut-être aurait-il
fait autrement si le ballon avait
présenté un danger dans cette zone des
Vincent kilomètres mais ils ont voulu se
rapporter une situation connue donc oui
ça crée un précédent parce que
de base mais parce que on en a pas
besoin des satellites au-dessus de nos
têtes alors pour notre économie pour la
fin non mais là pour le GPS je parle de
la zone des 20 centimes et les
satellites sont au-dessus de la zone de
Karman la fameuse volontairement des
questions dans l'espace
pour nos téléspectateurs au dessus des
100 km commence l'espace à proprement
parler qu'on appelle l'espace extra
atmosphérique on est vraiment en dehors
de l'atmosphère même si encore quelques
petites particules qui se baladent c'est
pas le sujet on est vraiment dans
l'espace à proprement parler et là c'est
une zone internationale et de non droit
voilà donc chacun fait ce qu'il veut
c'est un véritable Far West ce qui n'est
pas le cas encore enfin ce qui n'est pas
le cas de la zone 20 100 km sur la
réaction américaine
Jean-François Huchet peut-être pour nous
éclairer sur l'état de l'opinion ou des
médias américains depuis le début de
depuis l'apparition de ce ballon c'est
quoi c'est une espèce de Crescendo
d'hystérique quel terme vous employez
pour qualifier ce qui s'est passé
la question de la rivalité avec la Chine
on le sait est une question qui
s'imposait
de manière un peu périphérique dans les
campagnes électorales là aujourd'hui on
peut dire même déjà à la fin du mandat
Obama c'était devenu déjà une question
comme on dit partisane c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a un accord très fort entre
républicains et démocrate pour pour
avancer vers un contrôle de l'expansion
chinoise et puis Trump on l'a vu
des sanctions très fortes et on s'était
un peu posé la question avec Biden mais
on a vu très vite que Joe Biden ne
voulait pas revenir sur toutes les
sanctions qui ont été prises sous Trump
voire même les durcir donc il y a un
état aujourd'hui aux États-Unis
qui conduit je pense l'opinion publique
américaine à avoir la Chine comme un
ennemi il faut dire que la Chine n'est
pas non plus de son côté aussi à penser
à autre chose quand on voit les
réactions qui a pu avoir sur la visite
de Nancy Pelosi à Taïwan sur un certain
nombre de provocations du vocabulaire
qui est utilisé et puis cette Chine qui
se referme sur elle-même donc oui il y a
effectivement une sorte je dirais un peu
d'hystérie aussi qui est en train de
gagner aussi peut-être aussi les médias
américains
et je pense que si ce qui explique aussi
l'embarin des des gouvernements à
l'heure actuelle qui cherchent eux à
faire baisser un peu l'attention et
peut-être voilà essayer de de faire
repartir les les relations
entre l'Amérique et les États-Unis sur
une voie un peu moins de confrontation
on a la même chose entre entre l'Inde et
la Chine c'est c'est peu près la même
chose
c'est à dire des tensions les médias
indiens sont frontières dans certaines
frontières et les médias hystériques et
des gouvernements qui essayent un peu
d'apaiser c'est ça intéressant Emilie
est-ce que justement en Europe et en
France on est peut-être pas assez
méfiant parce que on voit qu'il y a une
transformation aussi en termes
d'investissement je parle en termes
économique de la Chine qui investissait
beaucoup dans des entreprises puis
maintenant qui investit un petit peu
plus dans la R&D des choses un peu moins
voyantes dans des startups c'est un peu
moins visible et du coup est-ce que
c'est c'est pas une façon aussi de se
voiler un peu la face il y a des
cyberattaques aussi il y a l'agence qui
s'occupe des cyberattaques cybersécurité
qui dit il y en a de plus en plus qui
viennent de la Chine est-ce que nous on
n'est pas un peu parfois un peu naïf ou
pas assez prudent je pense que deux
personnes peuvent répondre à la question
peut-être valorité pour commencer et
puis ensuite une réponse un peu plus
cyber ça peut être intéressant aussi
d'en dire un mot la Chine parce que
l'Europe est un peu naïve beaucoup moins
qu'elle ne l'était il y a 5 ou 6 ans
donc depuis le milieu des années 2010 il
y a eu une véritable évolution justement
y compris dans les pays comme
l'Allemagne et avant même la guerre en
Ukraine où on voyait la Chine acheter
certaines sociétés de haute technologie
surtout en Allemagne d'ailleurs plus
qu'ailleurs parce que c'est là que se
trouvait des des éléments qui
intéressaient donc les choses sont
beaucoup moins naïves encore une fois
l'Europe a défini sa politique chinoise
avec cette ce triptyque de rival
systémique
compétiteur économique et éventuellement
partenaires sur certains sujets qui sont
toujours les mêmes la prolifération le
climat etc et qui sont là un peu pour
maintenir des éléments de dialogue ce
qui est sur en revanche c'est que
l'Europe comme la France ne souhaite pas
s'engager sur une logique qui serait de
confrontation systématique contre la
Chine qualifiée des nuits principales et
ça c'est une différence qu'on peut avoir
avec certains aux États-Unis pas tous
mais y compris chez les démocrates et
encore plus chez les républicains et
chez certains auteurs européens comme
les pays baltes par exemple
ou même enfin de certains États
européens qui par souci de rester
beaucoup plus proche de Washington les
Britanniques également récemment ils
avaient une position différente avant
souhaite que l'Europe s'assieme beaucoup
plus anti-chinoise entre guillemets pour
finalement qui est pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre la position des
États-Unis et la position de l'Union
européenne alors double question sur les
moyens utilisés par la Chine
effectivement pour espionner l'Europe ça
je trouve ça intéressant et puis parce
que nous on fait aussi parce que
j'imagine on n'est pas on n'est pas en
reste non plus on a quelques moyens
d'espionnage
oui alors déjà sur la question de la
naïveté sur votre question de la naïveté
et de la feuille de papier à cigarette
entre la position européenne et
américaine un exemple très concret
Huawei est interdit aux États-Unis il y
a aucun problème en Europe voilà ça
c'est très concret après jusque-là après
après
la volonté il y a des problèmes
justement ça pose des problèmes cette
autorisation en termes justement
d'espionnage parler de cyberespionnage
là c'est un c'est un poste avancé de
fait et plus généralement dire la
présence de Huawei sur le sur le
territoire de matériel venant de Huawei
parce que très clairement vous pouvez
techniquement faire en sorte que ce soit
des mouchards voilà aussi simple que ça
en terme de collecte de données et de
rapatriement de données ensuite
directement par la firme vers la Chine
voilà et connecter naturellement en
partie communiste chinois voilà et en
termes de de volonté chinoise
je parle sous votre contrôle mais il
faut quand même observer qu'il y a quand
même ces fameuses nouvelles routes de la
soie ces nouvelles routes de la soie
c'est une volonté d'expansion sans
précédent qui quand même traduit une
volonté civilisationnelle de la Chine et
s'il y a une certaine sensibilité avec
cette histoire de ballon entre la Chine
et les États-Unis c'est sans doute le
signal faible fort en l'occurrence
d'ailleurs de quelque chose de plus
profond qui est en train de jouer ok je
vais vous redonner la parole sur nous
nos moyens d'espionnage à nous parce que
je pense qu'on n'est pas non plus en
reste mais peut-être votre éclairage
justement sur les nouvelles routes de la
soie ou une volonté je sais pas
accentuer de de la Chine en matière
d'espionnage économique puisque c'est un
peu le aussi la thématique de notre
débat si oui depuis combien de temps la
Chine a toujours comme on disait tout à
l'heure chercher à obtenir des
technologies qui lui est d'ailleurs
c'était la grande différence avec l'URSS
c'est que la Chine a accompli les
réformes sous l'ancienoping en 79 qui
était fondé sur l'ouverture les réformes
économiques et donc la Chine est devenue
extrêmement attractive et non seulement
la Chine cherche à espionner mais elle a
été sa tâche a été très facilité par le
nombre d'entreprises occidentales qui
étaient tout à fait prêts à transférer
des technologies à travailler avec la
Chine et ça ça a duré et ça reste encore
vrai avec des investissements en Chine
enfin donc c'est quelque chose qui est
qui fait partie de la force de la Chine
c'est sa capacité son attractivité qui
diminue un peu aujourd'hui mais qui est
encore réel donc ça n'est pas du tout
nouveau après les routes de la soie ça
date de Sitting est arrivé au pouvoir il
a lancé ce grand schéma des routes de la
soie il y a aussi les bricks avec les
l'un de la Russie etc et tout ça sous
les noms d'hiver est en fait une
stratégie à la fois d'investissement et
d'influence de la Chine destinée à
renforcer le camp entre guillemets
anti-américains pour faire très simple
mais qui existait déjà avant Mao avait
une stratégie très offensive en Afrique
sur d'autres bases donc en fait l'idée
c'est de d'affaiblir les positions a
commencé par les États-Unis et de
renforcer les positions chinoises par
tout un tas de formats qui peuvent
prendre un nom ou un autre mais qui qui
sont permanents un mot sur notre
capacité de réaction nous aussi on
espionne forcément sinon toutes les
démocraties modernes ont des moyens et
coopèrent sur un certain nombre de
sujets qui font consensus voilà
donc en creux vous comprendrez que
l'économie ne fait pas consensus donc la
coopération n'est sans doute moins fort
et là vous pouvez avoir des alliés vous
avez sinon des ennemis en tout cas des
compétiteurs j'ajoute que sur ce point
là dans les documents officiels de
l'OTAN sauf
erreur de ma part la Chine n'est pas
reconnue comme une menace ou comme un
ennemi pour reprendre cette rhétorique
mais comme un défi ce qui en dit long
alors à parler justement de la
communication chinoise avec vous Emilie
on est sur cet aspect sur cette histoire
de ballon on est qu'on est un peu dans
le classique vous diriez ça oui moi je
dirais que c'est fidèle ou pratique
habituel cette communication de la Chine
dans l'affaire des ballons qui ont
survolé les États-Unis premier temps on
est offusqué la Chine prétend que cette
histoire est une occasion de plus pour
la calomnier c'est ce qu'on entend dans
les propos du porte-parole du ministère
chinois des Affaires étrangères on
écoute tout de suite
l'entrée accidentelle de l'avion civile
sans pilote chinois dans l'espace aérien
américain est un incident totalement
accidentel et isolé due à un cas de
force majeure la Chine a expliqué à
plusieurs reprises la situation aux
États-Unis l'abus de force et l'escalade
de la situation par les États-Unis voit
à l'encontre de l'esprit du droit
international aujourd'hui ils exagèrent
et exacerbent la situation s'en servant
comme excuse pour sanctionner
illégalement des entreprises et des
organisations chinoises la Chine est
fortement mécontente elle prendra les
mesures nécessaires pour défendre
résolument les droits et intérêts légaux
des entreprises et organisations
chinoise en fait la Chine elle utilisait
déjà la même rhétorique pendant la crise
covid je pense qu'on vous en souvenez
l'ambassade de Chine en France avait
ainsi signalé sur Twitter que calomnier
la Chine n'aidera pas n'aiderait pas à
chasser le virus il pensait en gros que
certains médias et politiciens
cherchaient tout simplement un bouc
émissaire le l'idée de se mettre en
victime donc ça c'était le premier temps
de la communication on est offusqué
deuxième temps deuxième temps la
reconnaissance essentiel oui c'est bien
un ballon chinois mais loin de l'idée
des des Chinois d'espionner les
États-Unis on est plutôt donc sur des
outils qui sont dédiés à la recherche et
à la surveillance météorologique
involontairement arriver au-dessus du
territoire américain au royaume chinois
difficile de connaître la vérité on se
souvient encore une fois des origines
douteuses de la pandémie on n'a jamais
su vraiment quel était la fin de
l'histoire et du manque de transparence
en début de crise c'est même un
pléonasme parce qu'on avait quasiment
pas d'informations sur ce qu'il en était
quel type d'épidémie combien de morts
etc les autorités n'hésitent pas aussi à
transformer la réalité ou en tout cas à
la faire un peu évoluer Anthony blinken
secrétaire d'État américain annule sa
visite à Pékin à cause de ces histoires
de ballons les Chinois rétor que
finalement cette visite elle n'était pas
si officiellement prévue bon et ensuite
ils finissent par contre-attaquer alors
oui la troisième temps il est beaucoup
plus musclé c'est une attaque en bonne
et due forme ou alors si on veut la
rhétorique la théorie enfantine de
s'essuiekidiki on les États-Unis et le
camp américain en affirmant qu'une
dizaine de ballons on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure c'était des espions américains
qui survolent le territoire chinois
depuis 2022 donc et c'est une attaque un
véritablement on attaque plutôt que être
attaqué et ça ressemble à de gouttes
d'eau à cette stratégie façon look
combattant qui a été développé en Chine
justement au moment de la crise
sanitaire l'idée c'était la Chine est
attaquée pour sa mauvaise gestion de la
pandémie et bien c'est nous qui allons
attaquer des diplomates donc chinois qui
allaient attaquer sur Twitter l'Occident
qui allait vraiment se venger dans une
forme assez agressive pour redorer
l'image de la Chine avec tout ce que
l'aide humanitaire chinois pouvait faire
pour la pandémie pour répondre aux
critiques des Occidentaux bon finalement
même s'il y a cette volonté dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure de d'apaiser un
petit peu notamment vis-à-vis des
États-Unis leur politique étrangère de
la lycée davantage on voit que
finalement cette rhétorique elle est
bien ancrée dans les habitudes des
Chinois Jean-François est-ce que ce cet
épisode cette séquence on va dire des
ballons ou du ballon
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça ou est-ce que
c'est c'est trop tôt pour le dire alors
sur le plan intérieur je sais pas si on
peut aller jusque jusque là
je crois qu'il y a quand même beaucoup
de choses qu'on ne sait pas
dans les discussions qui peuvent se
passer derrière le secret qui existe
autour de décisions chinoises à ce
niveau là il y a peut-être aussi des
dissensions peut-être y a-t-il une
récupération aussi de cet incident pour
justement
ne pas voir cette des escalade il peut y
avoir vraiment des différences de vue
extrêmement importante après
ce qu'a dit Valérie je crois on
doit le garder en mémoire c'est à dire
que la Chine est dans une posture un peu
compliquée aujourd'hui sur le plan
international je pense que cette
histoire des ballons justement à l'image
de ce qui s'est passé sur le covid sur
la covid n'arrange pas non plus la
manière dont la Chine se présente à
l'étranger et on le voit dans
pratiquement dans toutes les opinions
publiques en tous les cas occidentales
je parle pas africaine ou éventuellement
asiatique quoique il y a aussi un
mouvement en Asie du Sud-Est qui montre
que on se méfie de plus en plus de la
Chine et qu'on se rapproche des
États-Unis je pense que cette cette
rhétorique n'est pas la Chine justement
à devenir une puissance
ni hyper puissance à la hauteur de de
ces capacités économiques et et ça je
pense que ce n'est pas un bon calcul
pour sitting s'il veut effectivement
jouer le rôle vous voyez de d'un
pacificateur de d'une puissance qui va
pouvoir concurrencer véritablement les
États-Unis avec vous voyez des objectifs
assez généreux à à l'égard du reste de
la planète donc je dirais que ça ne va
pas dans le bon sens en tous les cas
pour sites si on se projette un peu on
va terminer là-dessus on peut imaginer
la visite d'Anthony blinken qui a donc
été annulé ou suspendu va pouvoir
revenir à l'agenda ça serait dans la
logique du relatif réchauffement entre
les deux pays
parce que d'abord il faut voir comment
vont se tenir les assemblées nationales
en Chine qui en fait en terrine et
nomination au congrès au niveau de
l'État ça c'est début mars donc ils
viennent avant ça me paraît difficile et
puis ensuite il y a cette histoire de la
visite éventuelle du nouveau speaker de
la Chambre des Représentants républicain
cette fois-ci qui a dit que lui aussi
voulait aller à Taïwan donc tout va
dépendre en fait de ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis et dernier point on voit bien
que les Américains aussi une nouvelle
stratégie qui dévoile en fait qui ils
l'ont fait avec l'Ukraine avec la Russie
le fond avec la Chine montrer en quelque
sorte et mettre en évidence tout ce
qu'ils savent ce qui met dans l'embarras
effectivement les Chinois étant que ça
continue c'est vrai que ça rend les
choses un peu compliquées merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat Valérie le titre de votre livre la
Chine en 100 questions qui est publiée
aux éditions tallendier